peu de gens savaient que j'étais docteur
vétérinaire il pensait que vous étiez
l'assistante de votre mari même pas même
pas beaucoup de gens m'ont pris pour une
gamine une
disons une secrétaire
Halloween
qu'est-ce qu'il a ce beau
alors rameau à Rochefort des abcès aux
pattes dans madagas alors j'envoie
quelqu'un mais dans l'après-midi
seulement hein mais il reste filleul la
châssis pour une Moby qui est malade une
Moby qui est pas drôle alors comme tu
dois aller sur Audrey tu apprends je
vais le faire en même temps je vais
essayer bon puis je te rappelle aux
radios téléphone si j'ai quelque chose
dans le coin
où allez-vous monsieur reyby
hier et qui me pose quelques problèmes
côté mammite vous avez chacun votre
clientèle votre femme la sienne et vous
ne vous échangez jamais vos malades
ça arrive mais assez rarement parce que
moi je vais plutôt dans les fermes et
elle elle fait plutôt ce qu'on lui amène
à domicile conclusion on se croise
disons mais est-ce que vous vous
consultez mutuellement
est-ce que c'est bien d'avoir le même
métier sur le plan du couple ça crée des
liens supplémentaires
oui ça crée aussi des discordances
supplémentaires au téléphone n'est pas
tout à fait d'accord sur un diagnostic
moi je trouve ça très bien elle
s'appelle Liliane Reby
dans elle est mariée et maman d'une
petite fille de 7 ans mais ce portrait
ne serait pas complet si je ne vous
disais pas qu'elle est docteur
vétérinaire en milieu rural ça me permet
de concilier à la fois une vie de
famille et un métier que j'aime beaucoup
dans lequel celui-là celui que je touche
là à gauche oui oui
elle respire plus c'est simple elle a
les poumons complètement bloqués
[Applaudissements]
y a-t-il des soins que vous ne puissiez
pas donner qui soient réservés aux
hommes je crois que c'est une question
de force qui me limite il arrive un
certain moment où je préfère m'abstenir
quand j'ai en face de moi une bête qui
qui a une tonne
je trouve que c'est plus la place d'un
homme que ma place le vétérinaire en est
appelé pour un velage qu'en cas de
complication c'est donc dans ce cas
précis qu'une femme n'ayant pas la force
nécessaire pour accoucher une vache
madame Reby cède le pas à son mari et
elle se contente de lui servir
d'assistance
d'un joli petit cœur quoi
c'est bien
moi c'est une gamine
il pouvait pas s'engager comme il faut
parce qu'il était toi là
vous avez eu peur monsieur
et là tout va bien
et la mère la jeune accouché
maintenant
je pense que elle va se délivrer toute
seule sinon dans 24 heures on aura un
coup de téléphone
c'est un heureux événement une naissance
si vous n'étiez pas marié est-ce que
vous pourriez exercer votre profession
de la même façon je veux dire en milieu
rural est-ce que votre mari vous vous
apporte quelque chose dans la façon
d'exercer votre profession par exemple
c'est une évidence parce que je me
serais jamais installée en charolais
même en étant docteur vétérinaire de
groupe
je ne pense pas que des hommes
accepteraient d'entrer une femme je ne
crois pas qu'on en soit là
je ne crois pas en tout cas pas en
Charolais
[Musique]
je dis qu'une femme peut pas s'installer
en charolais seul je me trompe peut-être
il y a toujours des exceptions mais
beaucoup d'hommes hésitent à venir
s'installer en Charlène parce que la vie
est divisée en deux périodes dans cette
région il y a le moment des naissances
qui va du mois de décembre au mois de
avril mai ou le travail est
intensif on travaille pratiquement 24
heures sur 24 et il n'y a plus de
d'horaires il n'y a plus de dîner il n'y
a plus de même d'heures de sommeil il
nous arrive d'être réveillé 7 8 fois par
nuit
c'est pratiquement impossible pour une
femme seule de tenir un rythme continu
et pour l'éducation de Nathalie vous
avez le temps de vous en occuper en oui
je crois avoir le temps il faut surtout
avoir la volonté de s'occuper de son
enfant et j'aime beaucoup l'éducation
des enfants
et je m'occupe de Nathalie comme toute
mère je crois
c'est pas grave
[Musique]
et votre métier est-ce que ça lui a
apporté ce que cela enrichi elle
personnellement la petite elle a eu très
vite notion de la vie de la mort de la
nature
et vous pensez que c'est un bien et des
animaux oui il y a une sensibilité très
très prononcée et d'après ce que m'ont
dit ces institutrices à l'école on sent
qu'elle vit dans un monde près de la
nature près des choses
dis-moi Nathalie qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire quand tu seras grande tu as une
idée du métier que tu veux faire
c'est vrai pourquoi
pourquoi avez-vous choisi la campagne
pourquoi le milieu rural parce que c'est
un milieu que mon mari aimait beaucoup
j'ai senti que ça avait une énorme
importance pour lui et pour moi ça
n'était pas une un grand sacrifice que
de vivre à la campagne j'aime la rurale
et beaucoup de clients me disent que que
j'ai énormément de patience je suis
prête à passer des heures pour faire
quelque chose parce que j'aime ça ça ne
pose aucun problème pour vous monsieur
que ce soit une femme plutôt qu'un homme
qui soigne
ça nous permet dans ces conditions
d'avoir
une bible
les agneaux on peut les descendre ici à
la clinique et ils sont soignés
immédiatement puisque
maintenant ça s'est passé toujours assez
facilement vous avez du mal à vous
inclure dans ce milieu oui je pense que
on ne peut pas arriver d'entrer et dire
je suis là je suis une femme d'abord au
départ peu de gens savaient que j'étais
docteur vétérinaire il pensait que vous
étiez l'assistante de votre mari même
pas même pas beaucoup de gens m'ont pris
pour une gamine une
disons une secrétaire et alors avant lui
et comment vous êtes vous imposé je me
présente en me disant voilà je suis
docteur vétérinaire si vous voulez de
moi je suis prête à soigner votre animal
alors alors c'était oui ou non
et puis ça a été vite oui et puis seul
le résultat compte pour
si il ne voit absolument je pense
maintenant que les résultats étant là
une pensent plus que je suis une femme
ont-ils confiance en vous autant que
votre mari ça c'est à eux de le dire
je pense qu'ils ont confiance en moi le
fait qu'ils viennent qui viennent en
sachant très bien que c'est madame
rébelly qui est à domicile je pense
qu'ils ont confiance en moi mais
maintenant c'est avec le dire ça fait
deux jours
[Musique]
est-ce que vous appelez madame Reby
aussi facilement qu'un vétérinaire
masculin disons que spécialement on
appelle c'est plus souvent vétérinaire
qui vient que Madame Riby parce qu'elle
s'occupe du bureau elle reste en
principe au bureau mais elle soigne
beaucoup d'animaux chez elle c'est
souvent des fois des gens qui ont des
veaux
intoxicoses qui lui mène c'est elle qui
fait le traitement vous n'avez aucune
réticence aucune aucune moi je m'en suis
tout le bien trouvé au début quand elle
s'est installée dans le pays
quel effet ça vous faisait avec cette
nouvelle
soit vétérinaire alors disons à celle-là
il y en a quand même quelques unes mais
enfin j'ai pas trouvé ça
disons spécial quoi
maintenant c'est sans aucune arrière
pensée un homme une femme pour vous
c'est pareil
autant que les autres vétérinaires
quelles sont les qualités féminines que
vous vous reconnaissez par rapport à un
homme
je pense que pour moi c'est l'intuition
d'après ce que m'ont dit les clients
mais je m'en méfie énormément pourquoi
vous vous en méfiez parce qu'on peut
quelquefois par intuition faire un faux
diagnostics
gentil
quels sont les liens qui se créent entre
vous et les gens chez qui vous allez
soigner des bêtes
les gens chez qui je vais soigner des
bêtes disons rural on parle de la rurale
vous faites une différence entre entre
les gens qui ont des animaux du bétail
et des petites bêtes je n'ai pas je n'ai
pas les mêmes liés c'est une évidence
mais je ne fais pas différence quand un
client arrive ici je pense que je le
reçois vraiment avec un maximum de
gentillesse ce qu'il soit canin c'est à
dire qu'il m'apporte un animal de
compagnie ou qu'il soit
un client rural mais avec les ruraux
nous vivons une grande partie de l'année
nuit et jour pratiquement ensemble avec
de gros problèmes qui sont à la fois des
problèmes d'argent et des problèmes faut
dire économiques pour eux et en partage
tout il faut pas uniquement soigner
l'animal le dire vous me devez tant non
ce n'est pas possible vous n'êtes pas
accepté si vous faites ça il va frapper
c'est que vous soignez énormément de
petits animaux comme le vôtre les gens à
la campagne font soigner aussi les
chiens les chats non ils font soigner
mais c'est pas l'essentiel de ma
clientèle que je pourrais appeler
clientèle canine puisque c'est la
clientèle que l'on fait quand on soigne
les petits animaux Gueugnon est une
ville de 10000 habitants
[Applaudissements]
il y a une usine à une usine enfin
plusieurs usines dont une très grande
qui sont les forges de Gueugnon il y a
énormément d'ouvriers et
une concentration
urbaine amène beaucoup de petits animaux
peut-on parler d'une vocation ce qui
vous concerne
je ne peux pas dire que c'est une vraie
vocation ce serait faux puisque au
départ je ne me préparais pas être
docteur vétérinaire qu'est-ce que vous
vouliez faire je voulais faire de la
recherche nucléaire est-ce que c'est
excessif de dire que c'est l'amour qui a
fait un métier chez vous
non je ne crois pas que ce soit excessif
puisque c'est parce que j'ai connu mon
mari que j'ai découvert le monde
vétérinaire
uniquement en fonction de lui uniquement
en fonction de lui j'étais dans un lycée
où il y avait une préparation
vétérinaire je l'ai connu et j'ai pris
notion des animaux de la campagne au
lycée c'est peut-être dû à leur vie qui
n'est pas normal ça c'est bien possible
ça peut être très bien d'être dû à la
captivité enfin il y en a qui supporte
très bien
qui vit en captivité pour qu'on récupère
sa fourrure qu'est-ce que toi comme ça
mets-toi bien sur le bras allez monte
on en est au même point
les champions François que tu tiens ça
t'intéresse aussi comme ton père les
pigeons
tu n'as pas peur
avec lui vous allez vous êtes senti
vous-même un petit peu de transformer
personnellement par ce contact parce par
ce milieu par cette vie à la campagne
je pense que je n'avais pas du tout la
même attitude au départ
et inconsciemment je les fais je pense à
des tas de choses quand j'ai des clients
en face de moi alors que quand je suis
arrivée à Gueugnon beaucoup de choses
mettez étranges
[Musique]
vétérinaire mais vous êtes aussi une
excellente femme d'intérieur vous faites
beaucoup de choses qu'est-ce que vous
faites chez vous faites de la décoration
je fais de la décoration j'adore ça je
crois que c'est vraiment je peux pas
dire mon deuxième métier parce que ce
serait faux mais j'aime tout ce qui tout
ce qui est il y a dans une maison
d'abord la maison d'un vétérinaire a
énormément d'importance notre intérieur
prend une grande place dans notre vie
parce que les gardes sont très longues
et passer une garde dans un intérieur
tout à fait quelconque c'est affreux
qu'est-ce que vous faites disons que je
l'ai décoré selon mes goûts votre mari
participe-t-il aux travaux ménagers
et il est obligé de m'aider
quand
les horaires ne correspondent pas aux
horaires de ma fille par exemple il va
chercher Nathalie à l'école s'il est
libre et moi
occupé il est obligé de le seconder
j'essaye d'aider quand même le plus
possible parce que quand on a une femme
qui travaille si on admet l'équation que
l'homme que et la femme sont égaux dans
le travail et il faut admettre
l'équation dans le sens inverse
qu'est-ce qui vous aimez le plus dans
votre métier la naissance
un accouchement et
la naissance avec la vie j'aime beaucoup
un accouchement de brebis
quand tout se passe bien quand le bébé
est vivant je suis très heureux j'ai le
sourire d'accord ça se passe mal
qu'est-ce que vous faites malgré moi je
suis triste et ça se voit je suis même
un peu revêche alors votre métier étant
par essence même de donner la vie ou en
tout cas de d'aider la nature parce que
c'est pas un petit peu triste de soigner
des bêtes que vous savez être condamné à
aller à l'abattoir ça je n'y pense pas
quand je soigne un veau ou quand je
soigne un agneau quand on m'apporte un
agneau qui est en insuffisance
respiratoire je ne pense qu'à une chose
c'est de tirer de là et je pense pas au
reste sinon je ne ferai rien
vous estimez qu'on peut mener et réussir
aussi bien donc sa vie de femme de mère
de famille et sa vie professionnelle
disons que jusqu'à maintenant
j'ai fait un choix dès le départ de
pouvoir mener de front les deux choses
et pendant 7 ans je crois l'avoir prouvé
[Musique]